taxi driver Lake Hudson mawla has had
enough for weeks now he's had to buy his
petrol from black market traders who are
demanding exorbitant prices it's an
absolutely ridiculous scenario Nigeria
is Africa's biggest oil producer yet
there are regular petrol shortages at
gas stations
this happens because Nigeria exports all
of its crude oil output and has to pay
high prices to re-import the refined
products like petrol before I'm supposed
to buy full funding I'm buying it from
1500 naira how am I going to charge my
customer chocolates of me making my game
so it's really crazy some 80% of
Nigeria's revenues come from the oil
industry the sector is dominated here by
international conglomerates like Exxon
Mobil Chevron Texaco and she'll despite
its importance for the national budget
the oil industry has created few jobs
for Nigeria's 170 million citizens and
other industries have been neglected by
Nigeria's politicians for way too long
traditional industries like agriculture
and textiles are in deep crisis farmers
complain that the government neglects
them even though the labor intensive
agriculture sector could provide many
much-needed jobs that is public sonjin
give us water facilities guys easily
enjoy from the Omani I'm glass tea you
know deny of it forget Oh taxi driver
Lake Anson mola also doesn't expect to
see any benefit from the country's oil
revenues all he wants is to be able to
fill his tank for a normal price at a
normal gas station